so we're told that angle a is
circumscribed about circle o so this is
angle a right over here's this we're
talking about this angle right over
there and when they say it's
circumscribed about circle o that means
that the two sides of the angle there
are segments that would be part of
tangent lines so if we were to continue
so for example that right over there
that's a tangent that that line is
tangent to the circle and let me see if
I could so and this line is also tangent
to the circle so you see that the sides
of angle a are parts of those tangents
and points B and Point C are where those
tangents actually sit on the circle so
given all of that they're asking us what
is the measure of angle a so we're
trying to figure this out right here and
I encourage you to pause the video and
figure it out on your own so the key
insight here and there's multiple ways
that you could approach this is to
realize that a radius is going to be
perpendicular to a tangent or a radius
that intersects a tangent is going to be
perpendicular to it so let me label this
so this is going to be a right angle and
this is going to be a right angle and
any quadrilateral the sum of the angles
are going to add up to 360 degrees and
if you wonder where that camp comes from
well you could divide a quadrilateral
into two triangles where the sum of all
the interior angles of a triangle or 180
and since you have two of them 360 360
degrees so this is 90 to plus 90 plus 90
plus question mark is going to be equal
to 360 degrees so let me write that down
90 to plus 90 plus 90 so plus 180 plus
let's just call this X X degrees plus X
they off to add up to be 360 degrees so
let's see we could subtract 180 from
both sides and so if we do that we would
have 92 plus X is equal to 180 and if we
subtract 92 from both sides we get X is
equal to let's see 180 minus 90 would be
90 and then we're going to subtract two
more so it's going to be
is equal to 88 so the measure of angle a
is 88 degrees now let's do one more of
these these are surprisingly fun all
right so it says angle a is
circumscribed about circle oh we've seen
that before in the last question and
they said what is the measure of angle D
so we want to find we want to find let
me make sure I'm on the right layer we
want to find the measure of that angle
let's call that let's call that X again
so what can we figure out well just like
in the last question we have a
quadrilateral here cuadrado a be OC and
we know two of the angles we know this
is going to be a right angle we have a
radius intersecting with a tangent or
part of a tangent I guess you could say
and then this would be a right angle and
so by the same logic and as we saw in
the last question this angle Plus this
angle Plus this angle plus the central
angle are going to add up to 360 degrees
so let's call the measure of the central
angle let's call that Y over there so we
have Y plus 80 degrees or we'll just
assume everything's in degrees so Y plus
80 plus 90 plus 90 so I could say plus
another 180 is going to be equal to 360
degrees some of the interior angles of a
quadrilateral and so let's see you have
we could have Y plus 80 is equal to 180
if I just subtract 180 from both sides
of the subtract 80 from both sides we
get Y is equal to 100 or the measure of
this is 100 the measure of this interior
angle right over here is 100 degrees
which also tells us that the measure of
this arc because that that interior
angle intercepts intercepts arc CB right
over here that tells us that the measure
of Arc CB is also 100 degrees and so if
we're trying to find this angle that
measure of angle D that's an inscribed
angle that intercepts the same arc and
we've seen in previous videos that that
an inscribed angle that intercepts an
arc is going to have half the arcs
measure so this is a hundred degree
measured arc then the measure of this
angle right over here is
going to be fifty degrees so the measure
of angle D is fifty degrees and we are
done